I think our audience and demographic is  really sort of like I think we're  expanding now this might be crazy a  crazy idea but what if Derek are you  okay yeah hey you know what I think you  guys got this yeah I think you guys are  really onto something I'm just gonna I  got a run to a thing okay yeah I got IBS  so I feel good about that you feel good  that's great that's awesome you guys are  uh you guys just do what you guys do  your thing hey Derek how's it going Alex  great how are you I need those reports  by the other day okay yeah I'm gonna  just okay  Derek they're great they're on your way  on their way  hey hey you do now go ahead no please  please after you  yeah okay Hey  I'm gonna do it I was working here me  and Alex okay